here's the latest from the daily wire
when meta introduced its new social
media site threads to compete with
Twitter supporters dubbed it the Twitter
killer now threads is on life support as
usage of the new platform is plummeting
on Friday the Wall Street Journal
reported thread's daily user engagements
around 13 million members that's down
nearly 70 percent from its July 7th Peak
furthermore IOS and Android app users
are spending on average just four
minutes per day on threads for
comparison the report said Twitter's
daily users hover around 200 million
with the average time spent on the app
around 30 minutes per day
um
which is uh which is a whole lot in
Internet you know in Internet time
that's a lot
liberals had high hopes for Threads
because unlike Twitter under Chief twit
Elon Musk the left felt confident that
Facebook's new sister platform would
censor certain information chiefly any
story or fact inconvenient to the
Democrat media complex uh so anyway it's
it's it's failing which is um
was was really guaranteed from the
beginning I mean it was set in stone
basically that this would fail
and uh we knew that
really back on July 5th
when this happened watch
I don't think they thought of Twitter
but in that I am being facetious but I I
say game set Matt Zuckerberg because
he's really learned his lesson he is
really understands that it does matter
that you want to be committed to the
community and Facebook is is a very of
Instagram is a really terrific product
and Twitter is awful and my kids were
saying like why are you posting on
Twitter I said well it's free I said
well that's just Faith the worst things
in life are free
does that mean you're going to migrate
are you going to move your content
delivery to threads oh I'll put some
Twitter in just because I like beat I'm
a masochist who doesn't mind being hated
but that's been the way of my of most of
my life since fourth grade
as we know when uh when Jim Cramer gives
the endorsement you're screwed if Jim
Cramer says that that things are working
out well and then it's going to go at
your if Jim Cramer was your doctor
and uh he sat you down in the office and
said hey test results came in good news
you're fine everything's fine then you
know you'll be you'll be dead by next
week so threads was doomed from the
start sadly maybe entirely because of
Jim Cramer or maybe because there are
other problems with it aside from Jim
Cramer two big problems one is that it's
just not a compelling pitch you know uh
you're making a social media site for
people who think that Twitter is too
conservative so it's a site for like
leftists uh finally finally a social
media site where people on the left can
go and express themselves and not have
to worry about conservatives intruding
but that already describes literally
every other social media site in
existence
so leftists are not in dire need of a
place to go where they can feel safe and
conservatives will be censored again
because they already have that on every
single social media site that exists
except for Twitter
let me ask you something what if there
was someone out there who kept a log of
every single thing you did every minute
of the day I think that'd be pretty
creepy we can all agree well what if I
told you that's exactly what happens
every time you go online your internet
provider is allowed to store logs of
every website you've ever visited and
they can legally sell this data to
anyone they want that's why I use
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your internet provider can't
see or log what you do online now you
might be asking
well if I'm routing all my data through
a VPN then doesn't that just mean that
the VPN can see what I'm doing and log
my data instead well many vpns claim
that they have a no logs policy but
they've been caught logging customer
activity anyway expressvpn servers on
the other hand run through Ram this
makes it impossible for their servers to
store any data including logs of any
expressvpn customer at all so don't wait
use my Link at expressvpn.com Matt
walshow to get three extra months free
that's expressvpn.com Matt Walsh shows
and second the um
you know the conservative Twitter
offshoots in the pre-elon era didn't
work either even though they did have a
market to serve you would think in
theory they had a market to serve but
they didn't work either because
um and well they also didn't have a
platform like Meadow that's worth 700
billion dollars behind them so that was
a disadvantage
but whether you have 700 billion dollars
or not the point is that if you're
making a version of Twitter if you're
making the fill in the blank version of
Twitter
um it's gonna fail because Twitter is
already is already the best version of
itself
may not be perfect you may not even like
Twitter but it's the best version of
Twitter is Twitter
so if you want to and this is a problem
that we know conservatives have had not
just with Twitter but across the board
in the culture
is is uh and now we see it with the left
too
but for a long time this was mainly a
problem you had on on the right
where people on the right were always
trying to come up with the conservative
version of this
um
but you're not going to be able to do
that because there's no innovation there
right there's there's nothing actually
new that will attract people and
especially when it comes to social media
there has to be some kind of innovation
something different about it that will
make people want to use it uh there's no
innovation there's no innovation with
this this was just you know pretty
transparently a direct ripoff of Twitter
and
um putting aside all the copyright
problems there potentially uh it also
just there's no Market we already have
to come up with something new
which very few people these days uh are
are doing thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts